looks like things between the royal
family and Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle are rockier than ever everyone
wants to see a repair in the Riff
because it doesn't do anyone any good to
have this rift at the heart of the House
of Windsor the couple recently released
their new Netflix docu-series Harry and
Megan and while there's been no comment
from Buckingham Palace and Kensington
Palace about it a source tells E.T there
is no trust left between the royal
family and the california-based couple
especially as Prince Harry is about to
release his Memoir spare we're told
everyone remains wary about Harry until
his book publishes concern about what
claims may come out next I mean this is
a couple who are never far away from
their iPhone from their cameras who have
really chronicled their lives for the
last two years and I think there is just
a great sense of mistrust within the
family they just simply feel that any
reconciliation is not on the cards
because they can't they can't trust that
it's not going to end up in a TV show or
in a book another source tells E.T that
multiple members of the family are angry
about what was shown in the docu-series
particularly Prince William were you
flattered by the media attention
particularly no not particularly because
with the media attention came a lot of
jealousy great deal of
complicated situations arose because of
that footage of his and Harry's late
mother Princess Diana's controversial
interview with Martin beshear was
included it's something Williams made
clear he hoped would never be aired
again our source adds that the
docu-series would have been upsetting to
the late Queen and it's good she isn't
here to see it it was terrifying to have
my brother Scream and Shout at me and my
father say things that just simply
weren't true and my grandmother you know
quietly sit there and sort of take it
all in the allegations that Harry has
made in the latest three episodes of the
docu-series are so personal towards his
brother within four hours they're happy
to lie
protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
even if William hasn't watched this docu
series and it's my understanding that he
has and he'll be very aware of the
headlines he'll be very aware of the
damage inflicted on his reputation and I
think it also goes a long way into
explaining why the brothers are not on
talking terms quite simply William feels
betrayed tempers are high and there's a
lot of tension there's a lot of upset
there's a lot of anger and there's still
a lot of resentment and I think any
reproachment is is really quite far down
the line William will be taking this
very personally I think he's incredibly
upset and feels very badly betrayed by
his brother as far as the rift between
the brothers goals seems it won't be
coming to an end anytime soon he's
opened Pandora's Box in this docu-series
but he certainly hasn't emptied that box
I think there is a lot more that he can
say there is a lot more damage
potentially that could be done
foreign
[Music]